while 2020 might have been a relatively
light year for superhero movies
2021 looks to be a return to form there
are a slew of superhero flicks scheduled
to hit cinemas or at least some
streaming service playing the role of a
theater
and we have everything you need to know
about these upcoming blockbusters
sony dropped the first trailer for
morbius in january 2020
and it was met with a mixture of
confusion and excitement
the three-minute clip is essentially a
mini origin story for lesser-known
marvel anti-hero dr michael morbius
a brilliant scientist who turns to
vampirism after his attempts to cure his
red blood disease have mixed results
he gets super strength and hyper speed
but he's also left with
naturally even overpowering urge to
consume
blood morbius debuted as an enemy of
peter parker in 1971's amazing
spider-man issue 101
but he became more of a sympathetic
figure in later issues while his
loyalties aren't revealed in the trailer
we do
see him meeting with an established
villain interestingly michael keaton
shows up at the end of the trailer
looking a lot like adrian toombs aka the
vulture
keaton's character is seen in the same
white prison jumpsuit
he was wearing in the spider-man
homecoming post credits whether this
means that morbius will be directly
tying into the mcu by way of spider-man
homecoming
remains to be seen fans are predicting
that morbius will sow the seeds for a
big screen sinister six
while matt smith's luxurious crown aka
hunger is clearly the big bad
you'll get the chance to see it for
yourself when mobius comes out march
19th
2021 after years of teasing marvel
finally announced that a standalone
black widow movie
was coming dropping the news at comic
con 2019. by the end of the year we had
our first teaser for the film
a prequel that takes place after the
events of captain america
civil war after siding with steve rogers
during the dispute over the sokovia
course natasha romanov will be operating
under the radar in black
widow the first entry in phase four of
the mcu
making a mcu debut in black widow is
florence pew as helena belova
another product of the red room the
notorious training facility with which
romanov clearly hasn't finished business
the trailers have also given us a good
look at the movie's big bad taskmaster
as well as ramona's family from her time
in training rachel vice is playing
melina vostakov
and david harbour is a slightly out of
shape alexis shostakov aka the red
guardian he's essentially the russian
captain america the next entry in the
mcu film franchise will be released may
7th
2021 while tom hardy will be back as
eddie brock aka venom
director reuben fleischer will not be
returning for the sequel
taking over for him will be black
panther antagonist andy circus
circus made his directorial debut in
2017
with heartwarming drama brief and he
proved his blockbuster chops the
following year with mowgli legend of the
jungle the venom mid credits scene made
it clear that sony was plotting a sequel
and woody harrelson will be starring in
venom 2 as carnage to make good on his
creepy promise
when i get out of here and i will
there's gonna be carnage
what form that carnage will take even
harrelson doesn't know he says he quote
just rolled the dice on venom two
without seeing the script
you'll get a chance to see all the
karnas you could want on june 25th
2021 according to the hollywood reporter
marvel's goal for shanghi and the legend
of the ten rings is to offer quote
a perspective on asian identity the
studio has hired asian and asian
american filmmakers
to make sure that happens and judging by
the character's history that's a smart
move
the hands of shang chi master of kung fu
comics began as an unofficial
continuation of bruce lee's legacy
with a character that was obviously
based on the martial arts icon while
marvel's intentions may have been noble
the execution wasn't always perfect the
job of bringing
shang qi into the modern age belongs to
chinese american screenwriter dave
callahan
and japanese hawaiian director destin
daniel cretan
the titular role has gone to chinese
canadian actor simu liu who may be best
known for his appearances in the sitcom
kim's convenience crazy rich asian star
or kwafina will also feature
though her role has yet to be revealed
there's not a lot of details out about
the upcoming film
but is aiming for a july 9 2021 release
date
one of the highlights of dc fandom was a
role call for james guns the suicide
squad
which officially introduced the ensemble
cast of the soft reboot
biola davis joel kinnaman margot robbie
and jai courtney reprise their roles
from 2016's suicide squad
and they'll be joined by a host of new
recruits the director is clearly excited
about his anti-hero team-up flick
he promised that it will be quote
different from every other superhero
movie ever made and called the filming
experience the greatest most exciting
journey of his life to date
the featurette release during dc's
fandom revealed that plenty of big
action set pieces are in store when the
film arrives on august 6th
2021 but there's a catch the suicide
squad will hit theaters and hbo max at
the same time
so you can relax at home and catch the
flick or venture out into the wild and
do the same
marvel's upcoming eternals movie isn't
due to hit cineplexes until the end of
2021
but the film has already entered
production there's nothing concrete in
terms of plot but we do know that this
will be one of marvel's most eclectic
ensembles to date
angelina jolie leads a pact cast that
includes kit harrington
gemma chan kumayo nanjiani salma hayek
brian tyree henry barry keuin and more
the screenplay comes by way of matthew
and ryan furbo
while indie filmmaker chloe zhao has
been chosen to helm this huge cosmic
feature you won't have to wait an
eternity to see this movie it'll arrive
in theaters on november 5th
2021 work on tom holland's third
standalone spider-man movie
began in earnest when sony and disney
reached a new agreement
over the character rights in september
2019 but like countless other projects
it was delayed due to the coronavirus
pandemic the still entitled sequel to
spider-man far from home
has been pushed back to december 2021.
john watts director of holland's first
two spider-man solo outings
is expected to see out the trilogy and
far from home co-writers chris mckenna
and eric summers are penning the
three-core plot details still remain
scarce
but there's been some big casting news
in a move that nobody saw coming
marvel is bringing back jamie foxx as
electro the character he portrayed in
the andrew garfield led the amazing
spider-man 2.
it's a truly shocking reveal fans
already suspected that marvel was slowly
building to an on-screen sinister six
and the return of electro only
strengthens that theory and how is it
that holland spider-man will be coming
into contact with characters from other
spider verses
well the announcement in october 2020
that benedict cumberbatch will appear in
the film as doctor strange
might offer a clue either way the as yet
untitled film will swing into theaters
on december 17th
2021 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite comic book movies
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one